[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an action drama comedy
film called big brother
spoilers ahead watch out and take
care henry has returned to hong kong
after serving in the u.s military for
years looking to start a career as a
teacher he goes to his former school tak
chi secondary the principal notes that
he doesn't have experience in teaching
but after being shown a recommendation
letter from a higher official he is
given the job before henry leaves the
principal informs him that the class he
is assigned to teach is one of the worst
in the school the morning of his first
day at school henry walks into the class
to see that it is in absolute chaos some
students are sleeping others are singing
some are playing video games while a
good number of them are cooking ramen on
a portable stove even after the teacher
walks in they completely ignore him and
continue what they are doing henry tries
to get their attention but they pretend
to not hear him he gives up on trying to
divert their attention and goes around
the classroom commenting on the things
they are already doing the students who
are cooking are asked to eat less ramen
because it contains too much sodium
henry then approaches a guy named zufa
playing yooka-laylee and helps him with
it similarly he warns a gamer kid
against the radiation he might receive
from staring at the screen all day geez
if that's a real thing then it's too
late for all of us anyway when the
students finally start listening to him
he introduces himself and writes his
name and phone number on the board the
students laugh because his handwriting
is ugly then someone from the students
calls him and asks him to leave the
class but henry laughs it off the kids
ignore him yet again and continue with
the activities they were doing before
his arrival having enough of it henry
uses a rubber band and piece of chalk to
trigger the fire sprinkler in the room
the students quickly spread out to keep
themselves from getting wet he finally
gets their full attention and officially
welcomes them to his class
welcome to my class after class a group
of five lowest ranking students gathers
in the sports supply room to smoke the
leader of the group jack has a crush on
an a grade student from another class
the others find him staring at her
picture and make fun of him the group
has a rivalry with the rich and spoiled
kids from the school's basketball team
they enter the supply room and mock jack
as usual because he is poor later the
basketball team is practicing while jack
and the group watch them from nearby
jack drops a bottle on the court which
causes the team leader to fall the group
laughs but is given detention by the
school's english teacher miss liang to
avoid detention they play a prank on her
and run away when she is busy cleaning
her desk elsewhere the school's
principal is distressed because the
education board is planning to deduct 20
of their annual funding the people from
the board come to take a tour of the
school to inspect where the funds are
being used at the same time henry enters
the classroom where the students have
set up a bucket of water to prank him
but his reflexes work faster than the
falling bucket and he is able to push it
away the students who had been waiting
to make fun of him are left shocked
henry asks for jack's packet of
cigarettes knowing that he smokes jack
simply hands him the pack curious as to
what he is about to do then henry asks
zuffa to name the three ingredients that
are in a cigarette when he answers the
question correctly he is allowed to skip
class for the day everyone starts to
bang on their desks demanding that they
should get to skip class as well when
they stop he hands them all a cigarette
and asks them to analyze it henry knows
that if he simply mentions the effect it
has on their health they won't take it
seriously so instead he asks them about
the outcomes of smoking cigarettes and
explains how tar forms in their lungs
for the first time they pay attention to
the teacher and are actually interested
in learning after the bell rings he asks
them to return the cigarettes and the
students reluctantly agree that day in
the cafeteria the captain of the
basketball team makes one of jack's
friends bruce tripp on his leg this
gives rise to an argument between the
groups which soon turns into a fight
they throw food and tables at each other
destroying the place later henry is
informed that five students from his
class have been temporarily suspended
for starting the fight henry finds jack
fighting his opponent in the hallway and
stops them on being asked to calm down
jack accuses the school of being unfair
because the rich kids get no punishment
that day after school henry goes through
the files of all five students to find
out more about them the first guy is
named zufa the son of a pakistani
immigrant who is always discriminated
against because of his race he is often
accused of stealing by the policemen in
his neighborhood zuffa's only wish in
his life is to become a musician the
second student is a girl named denan she
was a disappointment to her father ever
since her birth because he always wanted
a son her entire life denon has been
trying to gain her father's respect she
even cut her hair to a shorter length
and played with cars to pretend to be a
boy yet her father doesn't care about
her while he treats her younger brother
like a prince
then there are brothers named bruce and
chris their mother ran away with a man
when they were only kids which turned
their father into an alcoholic the
brothers only had each other to rely on
while growing up bruce became obsessed
with video games to escape reality while
chris worked hard in a grocery store to
make money for the family lastly henry
can find no information about jack's
family background in the following scene
we see jack working at a restaurant as a
waiter an mma better jion yang arrives
at the restaurant with his business
partners when jian ying isn't looking
jack steals his fancy lighter but is
caught jian ying's men beat him up as he
checks jack's id after finding out that
he is a student he gives some money and
offers him a job as their food delivery
man somewhere else henry visits zuffa's
home and finds him running away from his
father and his associates after stealing
a ticket he helps him at first but after
finding out why he is being chased he
takes the father's side then he and zufa
come to hang out at a bridge to motivate
zufa into doing whatever he wants henry
sings with a band performing in the
streets seconds later zuffa joins him
and sings in front of people for the
first time since being bullied at school
years ago meanwhile bruce and chris's
father comes home late like always and
orders them to bring him a beer from the
store when the brothers refuse he yells
at them to get out of his house the next
day henry meets with their father and
convinces him to go to rehab for his
son's well-being in the meantime dinan's
father brings her a bag of makeup
products and asks her to act like a girl
for once dinan is furious at him for
always making her feel like she is not
good enough she applies the makeup on
her younger brother and sneaks out of
the house with the car key she is about
to drive away in her father's car but is
stopped by henry at the right moment he
tells her that driving without a license
is illegal and suggests an alternative
following that they go to a go-kart race
track henry also invites her father and
makes them race the father and daughter
show no mercy to each other during the
race and eventually end up outside the
track suddenly dinan's go-kart is hit by
a vehicle but she manages to dodge it
unaware of this her father cries
mourning his daughter's death denan
realizes that he does in fact love her
and hugs him the next day at school
bruce and chris along with a group are
sent to a rehabilitation center to
interview a recovering alcoholic they're
surprised to see that the person they
have to interview is their father the
students ask him how he started to drink
the man answers that he loved his wife
dearly but she left him at the lowest
point of his life hence he started to
drink and forgot that he had two kids to
take care of the man doesn't reveal that
bruce and chris are his sons but
apologizes to them by the end of it the
brothers are left crying somewhere else
jack has started to work for the mma
better jion yang he offers jack a lot of
money to drug a fighter's drink in the
next game jack is reluctant but is
forced into accepting the offer on the
day of the fight jian ying sponsors a
fighter but bets money on his loss jack
puts drugs in the fighter's drink but is
caught while doing so before he can
blame gian yang he is beaten up and
locked inside a locker a while later
henry arrives there and asks the
fighters if they have seen his student
the men ask him to return home but jack
from inside the locker yells for help
after finding out he is being trapped
henry attacks them and overpowers them
easily when the fighters step in it gets
a bit intense but henry dodges their
attacks efficiently by the end of it he
knocks out their best fighter who is
supposed to compete in a few minutes in
the following scene they are at a
hospital where henry gets treated for
his wounds jack tries to reveal the
truth about jian ying but is made to
shut up the news makes it to the
television and henry starts being known
as the man who beat up a professional
fighter to save his student his
popularity in school grows and the
students start to respect him they even
get up to welcome him to the class in
contrast to how they were earlier a
flashback shows us that henry used to be
a prankster when he was in school he
even threw water balloons at a student
who was playing piano for the parents in
an event later he fought the same
student and broke his hand he was
suspended for the fight after which he
had to fly to the states starting that
day the students pay attention when
henry teaches in class and study hard
for the upcoming college entrance test
everyone is doing great except bruce who
has grown addicted to pills it turns out
that while charlie turned to video games
to avoid his family's problem bruce
started doing drugs because he is
unfocused he does very badly in the mock
entrance test henry promises to help him
but bruce grows more depressed with time
eventually he jumps off the balcony of
his house he is rushed to the hospital
and goes into a coma the media twists
the news and blames it on the school and
henry for what bruce did the officials
from the education board interview henry
and decide to revoke his teaching
license when he packs his things and
leaves the school the students chase him
asking him to stay they are heartbroken
by his absence but they know that they
should ace their upcoming test to make
him proud from that day on they study
twice as hard to prove to the board that
henry is a good teacher on the day of
the test jack along with all of his
classmates get a text from henry asking
them to meet in the school an hour
before the exam when the students gather
they find out that it was gian yang's
trick to keep them confined in the
school so they won't make it to the
examination hall on time he is doing
this to teach henry a lesson a while
later henry arrives at school and finds
out about gian ying's plan he lets the
students free and fights all of
jianyang's people to stop them from
harming the children they escape and
quickly make their way to the
examination hall while henry fights jian
yang while they are fighting one on one
jian ying reveals that he was the guy
who henry had thrown water balloons at
when he was little it turns out that
ever since henry broke his arm he wasn't
able to compete in a big music
competition ever since the incident he
hasn't touched a piano and blames henry
for ruining his dream henry tries to
reason with him but is attacked yet
again they struggle to get a hold of a
knife at last henry gets in a chase to
kill him but doesn't do it he asks for
forgiveness for what he did when he was
little and walks away the students reach
the examination hall at the right time
and complete the test cut to a few weeks
later they all pass with flying colors
jion ying starts to play the piano again
but has a lot to practice before he gets
as good as he used to be bruce recovers
quickly and promises to attend the next
year's entrance test the principal is
also delighted because the board decides
to give them a 20 bonus fund because
their students did very well in the
entrance test henry returns to teaching
and does the fire sprinkler trick on
another batch of students subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching